take take your top enemies everybody has
enemies you got haters i'm not talking
haters i'm talking enemies yeah okay
so
what's the one imagine your top two
biggest enemies at the top of the
leaders bulletin take your biggest
enemies in your life you ever had okay
okay ever not haters enemies direct
enemies that are taking market share
away from you
one day you wake up with some of us
experiences about two weeks ago one day
you wake up your top two enemies unite
oh great
when you win that's what you meant when
you wake up and you're like wait what
yup goes to united holy [ __ ] okay what
did we do well here's an article to read
and you're in your general defect
exactly exactly voltron
so watch this here this is an article
today yesterday russia is with you putin
vows to back xi
in u.s row over taiwan visit now go a
little lower because i want to read what
the china's
there's a general all the way in the
bottom keep going lower look for the
general that's uh named z keep going
keep going keep going keep going keep
going oh by the way that's the video let
them see that video click on that and
look what's turning that's in moscow
okay
hey
we're with you that's enough wow okay
we're with you that's a red square that
is is that just that wow yes we're with
you we got you don't worry about it
don't put your door in message running
around that's moscow astanico tv tower
right now
china russia is with you hardly can
happen without an official approval
context needs no explanation okay so
what are they saying now if you go all
the way to the bottom of the article
above pelosi's picture right there
zao told a regular daily briefing we
would like to tell the united states
once again that china is standing by the
chinese people's liberation army will
never sit idly by and china will take
resolute responses and strong counter
measures to defend its sovereignty and
territorial integrity okay
so bring it back to us on the camera uh
for us to be talking about this all
right so iran historically has had a
reputation of
saying they're going to do something and
they don't to america if you do this
we're going to do this if you do that
we're going to do this like hey they
took hassan soleimani and what happened
they bombed the base that nobody was at
the base exactly just to say we
retaliated and we are going to fight for
a person now
iran will take vengeance during their
time but how long that could take we
don't know
the threats they made against trump
recently no question they said that
they're trying to kidnap trump basically
yeah so right i'm not making that i know
this is two weeks ago yeah i know i know
but but this is the part that's the part
that gets me thinking with this one here
there there's a few things in life you
have to be very careful with
if you have a reputation everybody in
life at one point made a threat that
they didn't deliver everybody you know
like you know you'll go to
you i swear to god i'm gonna blow this
place up you're just pissed off
let me say that one more time watch what
i'm gonna do i'll never come back here
again
okay but i tell you if there is one
thing like jennifer knows one thing i
tell you like jennifer knows one thing
if i say
we'll never come back to this restaurant
again ask jennifer for the last 15 years
of her night being together look what
she'll tell you just ask her you've
never been back just ask what she'll
tell you okay just ask so i wanted to
buy this you can call it whatever you
want to call it i want to buy the sushi
restaurant because we were in glendale
and they said no the person that we were
in uh granada hills you know which
restaurant i'm talking about down this
reformer don't just say the name but
some people don't know what it's a sushi
spot yeah
it's a great place you're private
chopsticks
this was 15 years ago and i love this
place
and i said i would like to buy this
place
and this i'm sorry we can only sell it
to one of our uh our kind so what do you
mean i can't sell it to you because you
mean humans you're not human iranian
they wanted somebody to buy that's their
and she says it to my face wow
i said i can't come back here man i just
can't come back here right so
restaurants so she'll tell you pat i can
give you 20 restaurants that that
happened to i value service and i
because i give service i value service
on return okay perfect you can call it
whatever you want i'm very comfortable
in my own skin this is who i am i'm
comfortable with this part
in life
if you make threats
and you don't keep them
people eventually just
know that you're a guy that just does a
lot of talking
no one is a hundred percent delivered
under threats nobody's a hundred percent
delivered under threats nobody because
if a hundred percent of threats were met
we wouldn't be living today armageddon
and this place wouldn't exist okay thank
god a hundred percent of threats have
not been kept in the world just so you
know okay
having said that
if you come out this strong and your
name is china
and you want to be the world leader
you cannot make a threat like this and
not deliver wow
which means
she has to know this
biden has to know this
we have to be on alert and we have to
know this isn't a small country saying
this this isn't a billionaire saying
this this is our number one enemy in the
world who wants to take over us they had
a vision called made in china 2025 it
was by 2025 china wanted to be the ruler
of the world
when they say this
you best believe behind closed doors
everybody needs to be ready for this so
now let's flip it
so let's just say there's there's
they're having calls behind closed doors
i want to ask you guys a question an
audience for those of you that are
listening to this i want to hear your
thoughts on your commentary
let's now flip it there's a meeting
generals are sitting there and one of
the generals says
president biden uh uh
speaker pelosi
you know what's the rvp's name uh
kamala kamala harris
nobody knows the vp but so if she's even
into rooms but let's just say
hey yeah we don't think this is a good
idea and we don't think you need to make
this trip and we need to talk to the
media about telling a different kind of
a story that a health matter came up or
something happened but you cannot go to
taiwan right now because china is very
serious now
if pelosi pulls out of this visit to
taiwan
how do you process it yourself
that's the question z1 and we found a
reason not to go and a weak
administration let it go how do you see
it uh
well
first of all the fact that
they own us right
that to them more than anything you
can't japan is more than china japan is
one point one trillion china but we're
really close to yeah but they like how
many
the threat is actually not directed
towards pelosi my interpretation english
is my fifth language but from my
understanding they're saying if she
shows up she represents america we have
to retaliate not to pelosi like they're
not gonna go slasher tires they're gonna
retaliate to us so if you like this clip
and you wanna watch another one click
right here and if you wanna watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]